I'm taking a couple of the supplements from Bionics research. I understand they are no longer
on the website, but we can still request them. It was my understanding that we could go and
note on our order asking for these products to be added. I have done that twice without receiving
it, so we need to call. Do we need to call and talk to someone to get these Bionic research supplements?
So yes, if anybody ever puts a note on an order and you don't receive, let's tell that note,
you have to understand that our system, our store is set up through a company called Shopify
and those notes are sometimes very difficult to see. So if you notice that there's this little
teeny little icon that on an order, it's real easy to miss. So if you didn't get anything in
your order regardless of whether you put a note or it was just missed, make sure you just call
the office and we'll get that shipped out to you. I did go to Megan who asked this question
and we'll get that product out to you if that today didn't already go on. So if you ever have any issue
with a product, you can't find something on the store, go get frustrated, just call the office
and we'll help you with your order. That's what we're here for now.